loved this film
i am curious i mean out of all of your
albums you talk in this
about how your second album my life is
the most important because of everything
you had going on then when did you
realize how important that specific
album
is what it means to you and what it
means to other people and
what made you decide that you wanted to
get deep and make a documentary about
all of it
well it was really um later in life that
i realized that it was such an important
album like like
two years ago you know i mean i knew
before two years ago
but it was later in life after 1994.
and um two years ago the world was
celebrating the 25th anniversary of the
my life album
um i was celebrating the 25th
anniversary of the my life album
billboard magazine was celebrating the
25th
like time magazine it was just going
crazy and the fan so i said um
this is the perfect time to have the
cameras follow me around
get testimonies from you know and do and
do a documentary on the my life album
while we're all celebrating and um it
was it's
extremely important to go back and you
know
talk about where that pain came from
because it was such a
painful dark album for me but it healed
a lot of people you know
uh formerly four million fans went on
board that album when i went to write
the album
i wasn't coming from a place where you
know i want everybody to see how
vulnerable i am i just was dying and
going through hell and i just wanted to
be happy and you know i just wanted to
be free from all this pain and then the
four million people responded and were
like well mary we're suffering too
so you know it was a pivotal point in my
life you know where the fans
actually helped me to you know see
subconsciously that well i can't just
kill myself now
because i'm i'm responsible for a whole
bunch of lives right now
so i had to go back and let people see
where the pain came from and
just how much pain since then
you know it's just was painful yeah
i'm also a concert photographer and i
photographed you in concert so i've seen
first hand that connection that you have
with your fans in that sense
what's it like to hear so many of those
stories over the years of your career
and to hear
about so many people whose lives you've
helped does it feel like both this
beautiful blessing and really kind of
the heaviest burden to hear the pain
that
all of these other people have gone
through but how you've helped to uplift
them
well it's definitely feel it's a
beautiful blessing but it's a
responsibility now
you know it's like wow you know but at
the same time
you know what i love about my fans is
that they know
that my life is imperfect as well and
i'm not going to always get it right
but they respect the fact that i respect
that this is
responsibility you know that i know that
they their children
they have children now that i have to
look out for you know
so you know they it's a beautiful thing
but
you know it's it's a huge responsibility
did you understand the rules and the
boundaries that you were breaking early
on in your career or was that something
that you also
needed some time and reflection to come
to that conclusion
i had no idea what i was doing early in
my career i was afraid
i was on guard i didn't trust anybody
and i just was going
off on anyone that would invade that
space
you know um i didn't know what i was
doing until later i found out you know
that i wasn't doing a lot of things
right and i had to you know i was
hurting a lot of people was hurting
because i was hurting myself
and i had to grow up and realize that my
life is my life
you know i have to be responsible for
my life you've seen
this that you've pretty much done
everything that you wanted to do
so once you get to that point how do you
figure out what's next
how do you continue to keep things
interesting and exciting for yourself
and to be inspired
well you i think you go for the most
challenging thing the thing that you're
probably the
you know the most afraid of something
that you can learn you know
from and you just challenge it like with
acting that thing
i was you know i've been acting you know
in little things since like 1996
but you know these big movies like
mudbound and this show like um
you know ghosts and you know it's those
are challenging things so i think you
just go through for the most challenging
thing
and the thing that you've never done
before like the production company i've
never done that before i have a
production company that i'm
seriously involved in and you know
when you're entertainment at some point
you want to be behind the camera or you
want to be
you know producing something
what stands out to you more the first
time you heard one of your songs on the
radio or the first time you saw
a movie poster or a trailer for
something you had an acting role in
the first time i heard my song on the
radio that stands out
because i knew that moment i was going
to be able to
take my family you know out of the miser
the misery in the
environment we was living in i knew that
i was gonna be able to
save us you know like get us that that's
that's how i felt about that moment like
you know how i get to get my mother out
of these projects i get to get my
sisters and you know my family
out of here when it comes to acting
roles
do you have like a dream project you'd
like to do is there somebody
from history or from some sort of source
material you'd love the opportunity to
play
you know i don't right now i'm just
trying to focus on what i'm doing i
don't have a dream
except to be great at what i'm doing
right now with this tv show
have you found that you enjoy especially
after doing you know you have this show
but you also did the umbrella academy
before that
are you enjoying getting to spend a bit
longer period of time with the character
and getting to really
delve into someone yes i love it
um i love cr the the writer
you know that writes this stuff and i
love being able to feel
or you know fill in this character with
all these real
places i have to travel i love it yeah
if someone told you 25 years ago when
you put
this album out that you'd be where you
are now how would you have reacted to
that do you think the younger version of
you
would have just thought that was crazy
yes
i would have been like yeah whatever
right
how do you think that version of you
would feel about
the the life path you've had i mean
would that you how i mean how excited
would they be about
that that me would not be able to handle
any of this because
you have to be you have to be um a
mature
a more mature responsible kind person
and
that person wasn't too kind she wasn't
responsible
she didn't trust anybody she was bad
i love that you can reflect on that now
though so that's that's the important
part
well awesome i appreciate you talking to
me about this so much i loved
how this film was done and and thank you
thank you christina